so i am what i found interesting was
that you originally thought about making
this as a documentary rather than a
narrative film and i wanted to know how
close did you actually come to pulling
the trigger on this being a dock
not not close at all actually not close
at all it was um it was like a first
kind of first impetus like a first idea
um that i had because i thought like oh
what a fascinating thing that this you
know condition actually exists and
you know is sort of like growing in um
in teenagers but i also felt uh that in
reality like the themes that i kind of
wanted to explore and the story that i
wanted to tell i didn't really want to
do that like within a in a real world
setting you know or like necessarily
have
in a sense a position towards species
dysphoria or make a film about species
dysphoria so that was quite clear to me
early on so it was kind of more like um
i guess you know i have a background in
journalism and documentaries so it was
more like a a light bulb like a trigger
um and a jumping off point but then i i
quite quickly departed and decided to
just write my my fiction narrative
uh one of the things that's interesting
is every director i've spoken to talks
about how um making any movie is a
miracle right uh just getting the
financing to make anything so um i'm
curious for you with making this project
how difficult was it actually to get the
financing because you're not telling a
narrative story that a lot of you know
what i mean this is not um this is a
tough subject matter if you will
you know oddly
i mean
everything of course like i completely
agree with every director like making
film is like
incredibly difficult but oddly the
financing of the film wasn't the hardest
part like we um
i think people were quite drawn to the
fact that it was a sort of like quite
original
subject and just
i think there is a lot of hunger for
sort of quirky
unusual
stories right now
and and and i and screen ireland you
know who were the main backers and then
actually i think it was almost like
maybe it was actually like i think
screen art had already basically like
they knew they were going to fund us
polish film institute was the first
sunscreen ireland you're much like that
was oddly seamless i mean the budget was
small like really small you know it's
like 2 million budget like a very very
you know very ambitious film for what it
was but
that two million
you know i think like i think the
funding bodies were super on board you
know and really understood maybe they
even if they didn't fully fully know
what the film would be i think they had
faith and and were were intrigued so
i think compared to other films it was
like an easier sell oddly enough
what was it like walking in those rooms
to try to pitch them on the money what
was like did you practice uh like your
one-liner and your you know your pitch
um you know what i mean oh yeah i mean
we did like i mean because jesse my
business partner so we we have a company
together called feline films and you
know we basically set up this company
when i had a
a 10-page treatment for for wolf and it
was like our thing you know that was
kind of the project for the company to
to grow on so we we just signed up to
like every european market possible
and um and we just
yeah we were just like
pitching non-stop like meeting after
meeting after meeting after meeting and
it was like so wolf is a film about a
boy he thinks he's a wolf
and it's just like oh and and it and it
kind of like it was relentless it was
relentless but
i guess like
i think the advantage maybe that we had
is you know you go to those markets and
it's like three days and it's
i don't know 25 meetings a day and
people are so bored and they feel like
you know you can just like see producers
like their eyes dropped off or funding
but they're just like not interested but
at least i think the fact that it was
kind of a strange premise and being like
no they're going to crawl on all fours
got people interested again of course
some people hated it and some people
really liked it but i i would say they
were like fairly
attentive at least
uh obviously casting on this movie is
everything um and you really need actors
that are going to fully commit to these
roles and performances um when did you
know uh we'll talk a little bit about
the casting process and when did you
know you know george and lily were the
right ones
so yeah the casting process was was very
staggered actually because i had so many
roles to fill and you know very very
complicated ones so
um
like
it was you know it was it was different
for each character you know um with with
lily i think like she did she was
pitched to me actually by her by her
agent and then i kind of first i first
saw her and i was like wow like she has
something really feline and i wasn't
planning to sort of like cast every
character like their animal but there
was something in fact almost quite
interesting about the like one of the
characters who doesn't really think that
they're that animal to sort of look very
cat-like and um
and we did we met then we did a couple
auditions then we sort of like worked
together in person
in paris and and then at some point i
was like you know she really you know
she really gets and she really went for
it and you know just got the character
and also like was brave in her audition
and with george like i think with
jacob's character like it was slightly
different because at some point i
realized like it's very very very hard
like because so much work needed to go
into like preparing for the physicality
of the role and the movement and
everything that i wasn't just gonna find
that
in tapes like no actor was gonna turn on
put a camera and be a wolf and um
so we kind of changed approach and
decided to just like look at actors that
i thought were really brilliant and and
solid and strong and just kind of have
faith in them and their commitment to
the part and george that's that's that's
how it went like you know we had a
really good chat and obviously he'd done
like you know he done like ned kelly
where he was extremely physical and
and he just you know he was really up
for the challenge and i think it felt it
felt very right and then we did a week
of of um
of prep in dublin with a movement
specialist and he just like nailed it so
so that was yeah so that was great and
then but then the whole pro you know the
whole casting i mean with each one of
them i mean it just went it went on for
quite a long time
well what's interesting is and i read
that you were getting ready to film uh
and then all of a sudden of course covid
um and then you shut down for a number
of months uh but i've spoken to a lot of
filmmakers and they talk about how the
extra time can really benefit a project
so i'm curious what did you actually do
during that down time that you think
helped make the film even better
so
yeah so i mean obviously like the first
thing was the heartbreak of like we
can't shoot would we ever be able to
shoot what is this like that was that
was that was quite tough especially when
you have that all that energy geared up
to jump into a film and then it's just
like nope there's a global pandemic um
but you know i was just very lucky that
all of my actors you know i think again
like i'll agree with most filmmakers
that you spoke to that i think
you have this like very particular
circumstance in which everybody is stuck
you know then in a time warp almost and
they are just about to do your project
so they can't really like audition for
other stuff or you know nothing is going
on so they had so much time to think
about their characters and like with
george like he did so much work
on crawling around i mean
like my phone at the time like i looked
like some crazy creep you know who had
all these like videos of like topless
actor going around on all fours on like
the heath and um
and yeah and lily as well like really i
mean all of them though i mean they were
and and we were just constantly like
chat like we would sort of zoom like
once a week and and have a chat
and he and she would send me videos of
themselves and and we continued you know
developing the character i continued
like interrogating the script i
simultaneously i was working with the
cinematographer like we were zooming
blocking
every couple days like going through
scenes so so yeah i mean it just it just
gave
more time to prepare really and i think
that was essential especially because
obviously kogit cost so much for every
film and there were so many unforeseen
costs that only preparation kind of
you know could save what that
effect was on on every production going
in that time
uh the first scene that they have
together um
is when they are both um in their animal
you know they're both there's no
dialogue they are both in their um you
know wolf cat
what
how how tough was that to figure out how
you wanted to block and stage that scene
and figure out that introduction between
the two of them and it's also an
introduction to the audience at their
relationship
yeah that was a really that was a really
interesting one because it was like one
of the few things and then the script
just said like
they walk around each other like animals
and um
and i always joked with them that like
if it was [ __ ] that we were just gonna
you they would know because i was just
gonna go for a wide like a very
cinematic wide and have two dots on the
rooftops but there was there really
wasn't any need for that because i mean
i do think it's one of the strongest
scenes of the film and i think we did so
we had as i mentioned this movement
coach uh terry and like and we just did
like so much like work of
chemistry
and you know them dancing together and
then going for and we and pushed and
pulled it and sometimes it was more
choreographed and then it wasn't and it
was just rehearsed rehearse rehearsed
and then
oddly like on the day what was quite
interesting was you know we tried a bit
of like i think it was like a hybrid the
actual the final product of of the stuff
that was rehearsed and stuff that was
completely improvised but then just
being like close to them and just saying
because they were so immersed in their
animal
selves that then i could just be like
break you know and then what you would
get was these like tiny like flinches or
quite animal movements like coming from
just inhabiting that character and then
breaking it with with a voice or a note
of direction so they could kind of go go
go b b b b and then break it and then
and i think it created this very
i mean i think um
sort of quite yeah sort of animalistic
and instinctive and a little bit
unpredictable moment
um which two like which
rehearsal built and gave them the tools
to have and then kind of the freshness
of men breaking that during the shooting
i think really helped
uh i love talking to directors about the
editing process uh because you know
that's where it all comes together so
what did you
what made you i guess what was it like
editing this and what made you nervous
when you first started editing and what
were you like super happy about
so
i i worked with an editor that i had who
did my first film um actually i worked
with like yeah both tp and editor from
for my first film so what was great is
that we did have like
you know a shorthand like an
understanding each of each other
um
i think
the hardest you know what sort of
freaked me out or the hardest thing was
just like the amount of material that we
had and like the amount of
scenes that i had written and which
didn't ultimately make the cut um
because what i discovered in the edit
was i mean i'm not saying it was always
of course it was called wolf and it was
jacob's piece but i think it had
slightly more of an ensemble feel
and you know when i wrote this script
for me there was an interesting tension
between the fact that without i never
wanted to tell the audience how to
respond to the other characters
but
in my mind there's a huge question
whether
the secondary characters do really think
that they're those animals
and i think you know with a lot of them
you can pick up that they actually might
have like traumas like for example you
know
german shepherd and wildcat clearly
states it but you know even like if you
look at parrot like and
you know spitting her food out and you
know little things if you pick up on
them and so that makes you question like
okay well why do they want to be in this
clinic you know and do they want to like
and are they searching for an identity
which of course i think when you
have that in contrast contrast with
someone like jacob who actually is so
trying to repress it but so
intrinsically feels that he is
you know for me that's an interesting
film and um
and then what i realized in the edit is
that because jacob's character is so
hermetic and so unreadable
it's
every time we kind of strayed too much
into like ensemble or other stories
it took away from him and that was a
sacrifice and that was um it was a
sacrifice that i had to that i had to
make and i had to do it in favor i think
of you know rhythm and of his character
and if we didn't feel with him and very
very hard character to feel with i think
and that's i mean george's unbelievable
performance but he almost says nothing
you know so you're just watching this
guy this guy this guy and if there was
too much you know song and dance on
either side but yeah it it
it did make me just that tiny bit sad
that maybe a little bit of the questions
that the other characters raised were
sort of
reduced
um in the final version and that i and i
hope you know i really hope that people
don't just look at at the film as just a
sort of like one-dimensional metaphor
about someone who thinks is wolf because
i think that institution that world all
of the different characters actually
inform
you know other themes really other
questions
yeah what is it like actually having to
pick up the phone and call some of the
other performers in the movie and being
like hey listen you were fantastic and i
know we shot like 30 minutes but you're
only gonna be in the film for like five
or ten
yeah i mean i i i'm thinking like did i
yeah with one with one actor i had to do
that like
and it was yeah it wasn't you know it's
never it's it's it's never easy you know
especially because
they really like were fantastic i mean
that that's i mean i think you know
i don't want to pat myself on the back
too much like i think as a director
always so critical of your work but i do
think the casting was was great like
really i was like so
in love with each one of them and it was
it was it was horrible it's so
heartbreaking every time you have to let
go of something or whether it's a scene
or a character or an idea even you know
it feels like
it feels like a small failure i suppose
you know and then you have to just kind
of
buckle up and think that's filmmaking
and that's learning you know it's only
my second film as well so listen
every director i've spoken to you know
there's always deleted scenes and
there's always choices you make in the
editing room it's just but that's why i
always talk to directors about it
because
you know that's where it all gets
rewritten that's the final write you
know or final rewrite if you will
anyway um so one of the things that um i
thought was interesting is the color
choices you make like the color palette
and so could you sort of talk about like
those choices and how early on did you
know uh you know the aesthetic of the
film and was it you know what i mean
like if you could talk about that
yeah so like um the in terms of the
aesthetic i had like from very very
early on there was a photographer that i
quite like um liked uh called alexander
gronsky and he had these sort of
he's beautiful um
i know the name of the tree but i cannot
remember it right now those thin ones
that are in the film
um
silver birch silver birch god you think
after spending so many months with them
that um
silver birch with these and he he's like
he's he's russian and he sort of shoots
in the peripheries of russia and like
had these like beautiful sort of very
soviet um backgrounds and in particular
there was one photograph which is the
cover board for my mood board which is
like a birch silver birch tree forest
with orange leaves and the sky is a sort
of like
pasty gray blue and there's a building
that you can't quite place sort of in
time but has a sort of soviet feel and i
just loved this image like loved it and
that really dictated a lot because like
from that we kind of built you know
initially you know i thought oh the
indoor garden has to be sort of plastic
because conceptually that was what i was
thinking but then i kind of kept on
shying away from that because
aesthetically like it just didn't like
it it was so jarring so then we kind of
with the production designer really
worked around that image and the other
images i'd chosen so like again like the
leaves and going for silver birches and
actually going for things that don't
really look that blasty ultimately but
because i i just found that
that kind of hybrid of like and and in
for example the therapy room you know
there's this the the
the dp's polish so he took a photograph
of the building in warsaw like knowing
again how much i you know loved this
photographer this like building in
warsaw and we printed that so instead of
having like in the script it was like a
metropolis you know like more new york
and they're like no let's stick to this
you know odd vibe that i had in my mood
board and so we used that instead
and um
yeah and then the colors kind of like
they all kind of sort of stemmed from
that and
and and then the costumes like a lot of
it so it was like quite a really we
nailed the palette with the designer
like working around all of those like at
first it was all sort of more blues and
greens and then we started playing it
just felt too much and too
claustrophobic there was also the idea
of it being kind of an aquarium somehow
like rather than a zoo paradoxically
because the building has so much glass
so kind of the blues and trapping them
in and i you know the photography is
always going to be quite static quite
steady apart from when we're following
them as animals
so so all of those things kind of
tapered out and then once we had nails
the design and you like for every room
again the pandemic brilliant because
production designer just did like
renders like and he would never like on
our budget like i mean doing commercials
in between have had the time like
everything was measured you know
rendered color like we would look we'd
go through them we'd block shots on them
it was it was brilliant and then
once we had all that we went for the
costumes and we tried and we tried and
tried and
that took quite a while and so yeah but
i guess probably all stemmed from those
first kind of those first instincts you
know that you have something that kind
of draws to you
um on that note i have to stop i've been
given that signal that says you're done
um i'm just going to say congratulations
on the movie and i really hope you're
making something again very soon i hope
you've uh you know you must have some
ideas and a clause
yeah yeah yeah riding away i'm writing
away already i'm not not wasting any
time you can't life's too short that i
agree with one thousand percent um on
that note thank you for giving me your
time good luck with that thank you so
much thank you have a fantastic day
bye
you